[Applaudissements]
ah qu'est-ce qu'on essaierait ont faux
de cette moustache gentil celle du
chantier qu'est ce que logiciel au cours
de cette moustache cheveux des singes
est interdit ni comment l'homme idéal
pour nommer des halles pour moi si tu as
mélange 2011 chan oui pour le sourire
oui
mokhtar déchets vaut que j'aime bien
[Applaudissements]
et lutte ouvrière battu voilà et la
piscine pouvait jouer je voudrais jouer
avec hbo drink à hestiun assez bonne
avec nous sommes pas tous parce que je
me comporte comme sa mère françoise
hauata sûr d'y jeter sur moi
on retient pourquoi villeneuve la civic
allez vous assurer que j'ai pas mis les
cheveux comme ça moi depuis oui je sais
il sort on ira faire la burqa la burqa
nous avons envie de faire quoi après
miss france les papiers jetables
anormalement bas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rendez vous à la préfecture en alu 18